[Applause]
him in
estar it's amazing for us to be here day
thank you for so
much we expecting
this about my Portuguese
Sur Den we are so excited to have you
here and I know that everyone here can't
wait one more minute to hear you talk
about the film um so for starters I
wanted to ask you if you could give us a
little taste of what to expect in this
new uh part of Dune thank you any uh I'm
very
excited to be with you and to be
welcoming you all back to our
re as you just heard when Zenaya said I
find great joy and great Passion living
in this world Frank Albert created while
this is a continuation of the story we
told in part one this film is a visceral
experience that doesn't require
audiences who have seen the first film
to enjoy part two saying this it's a
better idea to have seen part
one but you don't need to that we're on
an Epic Journey with Paul and sheny in a
completely new story of star crust love
Revenge ambition deceit set against the
backdrop of a massive
war once again
I designed I devised this film entirely
for the big screen
experiments when I set out the May to
make June my purpose was singular to
make a film that demand to be seen in
theaters the comeon all movie going
experience on the biggest canat possible
with the most immersive sound so that we
can immerse ourself at the maximum in
the story I'm very excited to be here
with you the
fans who made T part one a success thank
you guys and this is because of you that
we are here today thank
you so Den um can you tell us who is
back in Duna that that's how you say it
in Duna Paro and who is new to the cast
yeah do not part doise yes do not part
too
yes yes you just got a glimpse of some
of the new and returning cast in the
opening real but let me tell you and
show you yeah
yeah so uh there's po at 3DS of course
and shiny Our Heroes were played by Sim
shame and
Sanda you are at the Center of
everything in this film the old story
truly truly orbits around their gra
gravitional
po Rebecca fergerson return as
the as an Ever powerful lady Jessica
PA's mother there's ston scarg
guard he back as the evil Baron aranan
with his neew da bista raban
Aran
them is back as the fman leader
star and of
course Josh
Brin
returns as the as the loyal at fighter
gerni
alic and as for the new member of the
cast we have le sidu is
the
mysterious Ben lady Mar ring there's
lawence
[Applause]
PE is la is Princess Iran Emperor's
daughter and Brilliant
strategist and Austin
buer
Austin plays fed Ro the G SE most
psychotic but fearless and ruthless
fighter a wor wory enemy for
w and of course the incomparable
Christopher walkon as our
[Applause]
EMP I don't I don't think I need to say
anything they they said it for me this
is truly star studed man yeah I'm I'm
I'm yeah and I'm the luckiest director
to work with such talented people I mean
it's a Dreamcast for okay and these
these posters are
gorgeous they're gorgeous
gorgeous so can you talk a little bit
about the art that honestly I'm
discovering it with you guys is it
amazing you haven't seen it yet okay
okay it's beautiful
but I'm I'm so I I you have to uh uh uh
move forward
um you know the thing about these things
guys we don't three years so it's live
yeah vo so would you like to
meet you saying what I'm saying yeah you
you like to meet some of the talent
because I'm not alone today
[Applause]
should
[Music]
[Applause]
and the team show
guys come join
me
not expecting this at
all
[Applause]
oh my
God should I start asking you guys some
[Applause]
questions
J
[Applause]
all right guys let's take a sit and talk
a little bit about the movie so these
people can learn some things that you
have uh prepared for us so we open this
sequence with a fantastic behind the
scenes Sizzle Rio seeing you all on set
so let's start there um what was working
on this chapter of Dooms for you
[Applause]
all we're all so grateful I think and I
think a little bit out of a for words
this is such a beautiful warm welcome
and I'm so grateful to be here in this
space with all of you so thank you for
having us um but I mean dream director
uh Beautiful cast very very lucky to be
able to um to be a part of it you know I
really feel like we're all this is a
true Ensemble so it's you know I'm lucky
to be a small piece of something so so
massive
yeah and now Florence and Austin um you
are new to the Past you're just coming
in can you tell us a little bit about
your characters and how they fit into
the tapestry of the
story first of all I love all of you my
God this is
amazing so do you want to
you go D you go
my I play F who uh is is uh he's very
very Twisted I'll say that and I had the
Blast Of My Life get to work with the on
this and and with Timothy and and
Florence and the entire incredible cast
it honestly it's a dream come true and I
just had the time of my
life
[Applause]
[Music]
uh I play princess princess
arand who is the emperor's daughter
played by the great Christopher walkon
she's uh quick wise intelligent quiet um
I had an amazing time coming in just
hanging around with these people let
alone actually getting to work with them
um coming in here that the power of this
room is because of the first movie and
we felt that when we went on set every
single day so it feels uh really really
special being here with the second one
and um I'm very very
proud and now a question to you to um
part one gave us an introduction to Chie
so what will we see of her in part
two um uh a lot
more um
but um as I said before it was so
special to come back um and do this
again and actually be there for a bit
longer before I was literally there for
a week so now I got to actually
experience it and be be a part of this
movie in a in a bigger way and you know
just it's so full of gratitude for the
experience and and being able to be here
um so yeah lot a lot more she's got a
she's got a story
awesome now Timothy in part one Paul had
to learn a lot a lot of new things how
does his role evolve in part two well
[Applause]
Paul this is you know Paul is no longer
the young man we see in part one year
this is the evolution of Paul trades we
fully see him become the mad that was
described in part one play beautifully
bascar
Rising amazing and now I have to ask all
of you the stunts look like they'll be
even Wilder this time around um so for
Timothy and Austin what was it like
creating that intense fight scene we've
seen in the
trailer I me we had so much fun doing
that we had a lot lot of time we had a
lot of time separately where we were
both training and the moment that we
finally got to come together and start
start working on that and figuring out
who these two men are and they
individual Styles I just had a blast
with you
man same
here just fun awesome and
Anda do you
have do you have a favorite um
o action scene in part two I do I do but
I I believe that would be a spoiler so
I'm not going to say anything about that
you know just have to see when you see
you does it involve a lot of sand huh
does it involve a lot of sand uh yes
yes um Florence so princess Earline is
not a physical
fighter but that doesn't mean she is in
fighting somehow in her own way so can
you tell us a little bit more about her
tactics yeah she may not be fighting
quite like those two three um
however she's watched power and she's
watched uh intelligence so I think she's
learned how to fight in her own way and
that's that was the exciting thing about
her playing her I don't know maybe I
don't know we'll see what happens if she
just like whip out a knif or
something fighting with Mr W that's good
yeah so Denise the scope and scale of
the first film was incredible how have
you built on that world of Dune the
thing is that I used to see when I did
part one that it was the appetizer and
that part two will be the main course
it's a movie that is much is much more
action it's much more emotional complex
muscular movie and with more scope
yeah and with a love story sorry in the
middle
so I can't wait to share the movie with
you guys that's amazing um now maybe
seems like the perfect moment for us to
take a selfie what do you think should
we
[Applause]
stand
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
there's one lucky fan that got a black
T-shirt who's that
[Music]
person